destined to take over all of the uh
itunes charts and wherever else you can
buy of uh music if that was music rob
gronkowski getting ready to play for the
tampa bucket there's a lot going on in
that video he had a bottle of canvas he
had a puzzle in front of him that
no attempt to begin to solve the puzzle
uh cowboy hat uh no no uh no shoes and v
and uh gronk just hanging out getting
ready for the season one of the
intriguing storylines gronk on retiring
after 2019 out of football so today's
draft
the reasons why we don't want the
football season to be canceled and this
is a
a
a gift i was going to think of something
a little more profane to all those out
there who think that the fact that we
dare mention the struggles and
challenges of playing football in a
pandemic means we don't want there to be
football we want to be football and here
are the biggest reasons why
after the trivia question do we have a
trivia question i do it's a music
related trivia question because of that
great hit that we just heard from ron uh
rob gronkowski there what did he say
there now i play for the bucks hopefully
i don't suck is that what he said is
that what the line there is i just
couldn't make a high level high level
poetry robert frost robert frost is
envious he's from beyond he's just
trying to make sure he's in terminator
four like we've always been talking
about audrey buck that's gonna be his
only line here we go
what was the first kiss album released
mike you're a kiss album kiss guy we
know that where the band members didn't
wear makeup on the cover what was the
first kiss album where they didn't wear
their makeup on the cover oh wow wow wow
wow see unmasked was the with that that
was when the movement boy it was the
album that would have had lick it up on
it i believe but i can't remember the
name of the album i'll just say the
album was lick it up was that the album
it was unfortunately it was i got it
right wow
you better get it i mean you're obsessed
with it i mean you got
all that ugly gear of them
by then stop with that please by then i
had grown up by then i didn't care
anymore i just rediscovered them when
they put the makeup back on once the
music started to go downhill they took
the makeup off i didn't care anymore i
didn't i didn't like them in the 80s
right uh
and some of those guys without makeup i
mean there's a reason they wore the
makeup let's be honest about that so uh
anyway uh let's get to the draft thank
you i got that was just a wild guess and
i got it right feel free in the control
room to play that kiss clip of mike with
that number one anytime you want yeah
that's what i like without question that
hey that's better than the drew pearson
pushing off nate wright number one
without question
tommy in tampa bay i want to see what
tom brady can do
with a different team after 20 years
under bill belichick's thumb and now
it's all wide open and tom's taking over
in a division that still has a great
saints team and the falcons should not
be slept on and who knows what the
panthers are going to be and the nfc's
got some pretty good teams in other
divisions like brady's 49ers who were
his first choice for this season i am
fascinated to see what tom brady can do
what's he got left in the tank what can
the buccaneers with that offense do what
those receivers do with tom brady on the
field that's the number one reason why i
want football to happen i hear you we
need football that's right that's uh we
need it just from that you're i mean
that that's certainly i don't know if
that would have been my top pick if i
got the first pick of the draft okay but
i certainly was in my discussion there
because
you know as as much as you hate tom
brady well no i don't hate tom brady i
like the bucks and everything and you
know what's the other thing that's like
this and of course we want football i
mean yeah i want to see tom brady on the
bucks and gronk and everything that goes
along with it but then bruce arians i
want to see him coaching on the
sidelines with a face mask and a face
shield like he said he is too that'll be
kind of you know funny to see i don't
mean to like make light of that but come
on it's bruce arians and he's a cool guy
and i just think that would be funny to
see him all you know uh covered up there
all right
i i i unleash my homes that's what i
want that's what i want to see it's the
greatest player in our league that's
where i'm excited i mean that's where i
don't want football i think we're about
to see something like special happen
you know i i i'm one of those guys i
think oh i've already seen it it doesn't
twice there's more special coming baby
don't you worry this is just starting
he's one-upped every year so far oh
you're mvp great oh this one super bowl
mvp screw last year who knows what the
hell this guy can do he is taking the
league by storm so quickly it's
unbelievable
and he has been one of the three four
best players in the league since the
get-go and now i'm just you know mike
you've heard me say this i'm one of
those guys that think like the
pressure's off i think this is a team
that's just going to be like you know
just going to be like whoa we did it
we've already got over the hump we
believe in ourselves and we got patrick
freaking mahomes and i just think it's
gonna be like a lot of fun to watch and
they're gonna do a lot of explosive
things on offense
see i thought you were gonna go in the
direction that i considered going with
my first pick so basically i got the
first two picks in the draft because
we've talked about this it was carson
wentz in 2017 patrick holmes in 2018
lamar jackson in 2019 a second-year
quarterback every year that takes the
league by storm kyler murray
unleashed to me is more fascinating than
patrick mahomes unleashed because we've
seen it with mahomes we've been there
we've done that we know what we're
getting murray last year quietly because
he played for a team that was just the
also ran in the nfc west he quietly had
a great year he is an amazing talent he
can throw he can run the ball explodes
out of his hand the ball explodes into
the hands of the receiver i can't wait
to see what kylie murray does this year
that is
out almost as big of a reason as me
wanting to see tom brady with the bucks
i want to see kyle murray and the
cardinals explode especially with
deandre hopkins on that yeah i mean good
pick i'm i'm not gonna push back too
hard i don't know if it would have been
my second pick either um but either way
i mean he is definitely one of the
reasons you want to tune into football
this year you know yeah smart money i
would say yes he's going to be the guy
that jumps on the scene to where we go
okay he was really good and we were
promising as a rookie to whoa i think
this guy might be one of the best
players in football i'm with you mike i
think that's what we're going to be
saying when it comes december if we have
football and everything like that but i
don't i'm going to steal a line from
deion sanders here because i don't think
it's better than oh cam
oh cam newton and the new england
patriots whoo baby i mean come on are
you kidding me bill belichick with cam
newton and just seeing what their
offense can do yeah he's got to replace
tom brady and we know he's going to be
on edge because he's pissed off about
the disrespect he got this offseason and
everybody disrespecting him all together
i mean and you know i don't you know
brady had that like when he would get a
first down or come out you know let's
lfg i think that new england fan base
they're going to be loving after about
the third or fourth time cam newton runs
up the middle and does this little
superman and points first down that
they're going to rally around that in a
hurry too
and like what he brings to the football
team so i cannot wait to see cam newton
in the new england patriots
i was a little more excited about that
before yesterday when six
guys on the patriots checked out for the
season and look again we support and
respect the decision to do it but you
get a cluster like that all of a sudden
it takes a little bit of shine off of
what the patriots may have been able to
do yeah or may be able to do with cam
newton at quarterback uh he may have to
play he you know this is a team that's
got a long history of having guys go
both ways maybe cam newton's going to be
able to stop it
i'm kidding
i think they learned their lesson about
offensive players playing safety with
rob gronkowski a couple of years ago in
the right miracles that's not going to
happen next one for me and look the
first two are positive this one this one
isn't
it you're going to say it's negative i i
want to see what the 49ers do as the
hunted i want to see what they do back
in the valley of zero and zero i have
them at number two on the preseason
power rankings i have every reason to
think they're going to be the juggernaut
that they were last year but the
seahawks have jamal adams now we've
talked about kyle murray and what the
cardinals may be able to do
uh what and then the cardinals gave the
49ers everything they could handle twice
last year
what did the 49ers do when they reset to
zero and zero when they had to thread
the needle five times over to end up
with the number one seed last year and
it came down to the last drive the last
play of the last game before they nailed
down the one seed the pressure on jimmy
garoppolo after they
thought about
signing tom brady just all those things
that go into the stew what happens with
this 49ers team that we overlooked last
year yeah now
everyone is going to be gunning for them
chris how are they going to deal with it
i'm fascinated to see how that plays out
in the best division in football i hear
you i hear you and you know you know you
you got on you know kyle a little bit a
few weeks ago when he was like i want to
get back to the super bowl and get right
back to that moment you know and and
listen i i think it's fair what you're
saying yeah we want to see how the 49ers
react they haven't been in this
situation kyle shanahan's never been in
this situation like you said garoppolo
you know as well and we know their team
is talented and we know that so it is
going to be a different dynamic and yeah
are they going to work as hard be as
hungry be as crazy in pregame because
they were so hungry like we saw when we
were there in minnesota uh all real real
real questions no doubt about it and and
i'm excited to see how they react i'm
betting betting good uh as you know i'm
a little biased there
i want to see la i gotta you know sean
payton drew brees i think that's the
last thing i want to go with along with
taysom hill i think that plays part of
the dynamic of what i want to see from
my last pick i mean the saints are you
know an amazing team to me you know so
resilient with what they've dealt with
the last few years i still think they're
going to be one of the better teams in
all of football they're battle tested
man have they had some tough bull crap
type losses we know uh certainly and
luck has not favored them but drew brees
is last year you know a team that's got
an edge a team that probably feels like
damn everybody's talking about tampa and
they didn't even do anything last year
so between that and then how are they
gonna infuse taysom hill i mean he's a
backup quarterback slash weapon who's
making you know pretty good money this
year i can't remember what it was this
year off the top of my head right what
was the what number is he making mike
it's like a two-year 20 million dollar
contract so it's yeah but he's in the
eight figures i want to see how that's
going to work out and what they're going
to do and i would think taysom hill has
even more of a role of maybe playing the
quarterback position this year too which
is fascinating to me so the saints are
are one that i'm certainly excited to
see and then hoping for 2020 football
hoping
and they've got jameis winston on top of
everything right to make it even more
fascinating but yeah we want there to be
16 games we are raising the issues and
posing the questions aimed at ensuring
that the nfl is successful this year and
i know that there are people smarter
than us whose jobs are specifically to
come up with these things and i'll be
talking to dr alan sills later today for
pftpm about these issues what are the
things the nfl is concerned about what
is being done to get to 16 how confident
is he that we're going to have 16 games
played per team we're going to get
answers to these questions we want 16
games we want the full postseason we
want it all
but we also want to be realistic about a
virus that way too many of us have
ignored over the past several months
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports